[Aplausos]
[Música]
muchas veces nos preparamos mucho
ah
aprender no toda la materia hacer es
hacer
pero hay algo que a veces hemos pasado
que es tener una estrategia que cómo
vender nuestra imagen al final de
cuentas nuestra imagen
es algo que nos ayuda precisamente
incluso de verdad y ahorita está
comprado
en realidad lo que se ve los títulos de
tener todo el conocimiento
pero cuando te presentas a lo mejor en
un en una entrevista adicional
cómo te comportas
a trabajar ya tener una conciencia de la
personalidad
pues para poder sacar lo mejor de
nosotros e inclusive también saber con
qué nos relacionamos porque él
pues todos
[Música]
y puede recomendar decir
ahora sí que inicias de sentirse bien
para lograr tus éxitos para lograr tus
sueños
pues es creérselo pero desde adentro
ahora sí que esto de sentirte bien tiene
que ser un trabajo interno y para esto
voy a dar cinco recomendaciones
cómo utilizar a favor la personal
como las relaciones interpersonales
pueden ayudar a decorar o usar así que
crear 600 problemitas como buscar 500
y
obviamente siempre tiene que estar
presente el tema de la salud y
finalmente
un equilibrio entre la administración de
tu tiempo y el dinero y el primero
[Música]
pero en realidad cuando trabajas en un
ratito te vas conociendo bueno
si pudieras cómo controlarla
cómo utilizar ese conocimiento de cómo
es porque reacciona
[Música]
porque soy así
y una vez más
ahora
por belinda
es que el problema continúa
a mí me gusta
qué
a mí
sitio
[Música]
en mi clase tengas
yo soy un pecador
cómo
al principio
[Música]
y personal
muy barrachina
si les gusta
[Música]
oportunidad
en realidad el problema aquí es que tú
tienes que
saber quién es y saberlo
la personales
tengo esta mujer importante que a veces
no lo está
es como nuestras relaciones
interpersonales pues no
positivo tenemos amigos que hoy es
mañana
ahora sí que amistades con personas
[Música]
entonces el chiste es como estar
consiente en lo que está en nuestro
actor no nos ha llevado a mejorar o
realmente a cambiar nuestra personalidad
[Música]
yo no soy mucho pero este tímido
disfraz antes de vacaciones
[Música]
y diaria
no
[Música]
pero iba fácil
ah
boyacá en campo abierto y luego me gusta
y empecé a hablar en muchos ambientes
concretamente con esta ayuda
[Música]
entonces existe dólares
como las relaciones personales que
pueden sacar lo mejor de ti puedes sacar
los correntinos otros puntos que a mí me
encanta yo creo yo que donde más le
choca no se van a aplicar lo es en el
desarrollo profesional y la va
desarrollar es crecer y realmente yo
creo que la única constante que tenemos
es el cambio a veces es de mí o no si
todos nos vemos todos los días
[Música]
cambiando
yo lo digo mucho a mis alumnos es
importante el 13 la manera de crecer es
conocer si el conocer es prepararte para
lograr que el sentirte bien y segura
y preguntamos obviamente
un día muy extraño porque me subí al
avión y por siempre busco acordonada
y yo no te quiero
y
[Música]
este
lleno
todos los días
[Música]
a mi cuerpo
una objetiva
o no
no
en las
i
se siente una chava
[Música]
ahora sí
d
dónde
y no para poder hablar del tema
la única manera es estar segura
si algo que gustamos que no la
experiencia la experiencia
yo soy
[Música]
nunca es nada
si lo aplicó
desde entonces
una vez
[Música]
ahora nunca es un tema de un tema nada
más
y mucho
y yo gracias porque ahí estudié cuando
en mis posiciones
la dedicación a todos
tengo estudios internacionales
de los estudiantes
interiores
[Música]
del dolor
y ahora sí que una vez que tienes esa
seguridad pues el cielo después de decir
que el 90 por ciento
eventos de todo lo que hago gracias
la salud
[Música]
pero equilibrar y lamentamos los
emocionales ahora sí que como nos
sentimos adentro porque tú puedes
[Música]
es buscar
todo bien sé que con psicólogos
terapeutas con chinas
en realidad
para ver cómo está
80 dentro sí porque es lo que nos ayuda
y obviamente emocionado explicitaban
también es importante
porque al final de cuentas
lo que proyectas
no
y cuando estoy bien
porque se brillan los ojos mueve más
fácil
y por último es el tiempo y el dinero
final
hay que buscar
una clave que tenga utilidades no es que
no tengas tiempo es que no quieres
interés
porque cuando el tiempo puedes hacer
todo todo lo que tú quieras
si quieres la mañana
ah
si quieres hacer un curso busca la
oportunidad
d
un equilibrio bueno quieres dinero ahora
a trabajar
sus canciones para tener varias
oportunidad
personal para terminar 5 consejos hay
que cuidar la imagen
la manera de tu personalidad
y
al 80%
el 10 por ciento en ningún y para
animales y al otro 10 conceptuales
relaciones interpersonales publicitarios
y actitudes no creyentes
y por último las relaciones públicas
pero consciente si eres consciente de
les aseguro que las oportunidades
también por las negras
[Música]
así que
[Aplausos]
[Música]